(Audience Applause)
I grew up in Afghanistan. During the Russian occupation and
As a child I remember my dad being gone a lot. The subject of my dad's whereabouts
was somewhat taboo in my household because my mom told us
told us we were to never ask about him, so we never did.
Sometimes I wondered if he cared about me.
Growing up during a war was very difficult because we had bomb explosions
and missile attacks on a daily basis in the background of our
lives. And by the time I was ten,
these explosions were getting closer and closer to the city of Kabul where we used to
live. In fact, sometimes the explosions would be so
close that there's a distinct whistling sound that the
missile makes right before hitting its target. And you could hear that.
And in the meantime there was a
rumor about a regime change,  which was devastating news for my
dad,  who was a high ranking officer working for the current
regime.  And  historically the new regime
takes over by violently dismantling the old regime.
My parents were desperate to try to get out of the country. But they couldn't
because the government put a lockdown on everybody's visas.  They needed everyone to stay and
fight the war for them. The only way to get out of the country was on forged papers.
In the early 1990's, after a daring escape
in the middle of the night,  my parents and my brother and I
migrated to the US on forged papers
and asked for political asylum.
This meant that we could stay here temporarily while
they reviewed our case. They gave us a work permit and driver's
license, social security cards, those type of things. So we
started, all of us,  started working and our family in California helped us
get settled. In five years, fast
forwarding,
our lives were so normal
that,  the worst thing in my mind at that time
was how I could get my mom to let me stay out late -like expanding my curfew. And I'm
at my first job at the Men's Warehouse and my dad calls me. And I
And I could hear by the certain excitement in his voice that there was something going on
and he tells me you need to come home right away because there's
there's a letter from the immigration, and I speak the best
English in my household so he wanted me to come home and translate.
And for those of you who've been lucky enough not to be familiar with the
immigration system, they don't send you regular updates like, "Hey, still
thinking about you all, haven't forgotten about you."
So we were kind of puzzled by this letter and ultimately
decided it was a good letter because they inquired. You know
they sent a letter without us inquiring about it.
I rushed home and I find my dad in his security uniform
which he often wore and My mom comes home too
and my brother comes home because my dad called all of them and
I'm sitting on the dining table and all three of them are kind of hovered
over me and they're like kind of rushing me," Come on, come on, read it!  What does it say? What does say?"
And so I just read just the highlights really quickly and it says our appointment has been
moved up to next week.
And it says that we need to bring all of our legal documents. And our family photos
and things that are important. We start jumping up and down and we're thinking
"This is it. This is the appointment that we've been waiting for!"
And the day of our appointment we drive forty five minutes to downtown LosAngeles and
we go into a big government building. You walk in
and there's metal detectors, we go past that, and check in with security guards.
We go up stairs and there's an immigration officer waiting for us. And he guides us into this room.
And the moment that the doors open up. It was
like all of us looked at each other, we felt like we were in the wrong place.
The people that were sitting there
,they looked like they were visibly upset. Some of them were still crying. But we
still went ahead and we sat down
and they told us that, "Just sit down until you hear your last name".
And after a while, My dad asked me to go and ask
the security guard how long this appointment was going to take and what were we here for,
Because he was dressed in his uniform he needed to get back to work. So I go
up and I ask this immigration  officer, "Hey, can you tell me how long this appointment might take because my dad
needs to get back to work and he
says, " Your dad will go back to work all right, just not in
this country". And  it
was like my heart just dropped. Going back
is not an option because we were now considered traitors.
And I sit down and
hesitantly I told my dad this. It was like the moment that I
told him what the security guard said about this immigration officer said it's like my
dad just lost all the color in his face he just looked pale.
After a while, I'm looking over at my dad, he's hunched
over and he's holding his chest.
And he's visibly in some kind of pain and this
pain continues on, so I get up and I go up to the same officer and I ask him if I can
use the phone. He says no and then
I ask him if I could use the bathroom. And he lets me. I just
open up these doors and I
start rushing. There's a long hallway. And I'm looking to the left I'm looking to the right
I'm just looking for a telephone. And finally I spotted at the end of the hall and I
grabbed the phone and I dial our attorney's number.
Now, I was extremely upset with our attorney
because we couldn't afford even our own meals, yet the only thing
that we wanted to be sure that we could have was an attorney and so for her not to be
here was really
upsetting to me. And this girl answers the phone.
She sounds like she's about eighteen years old, like my age at that time. And I have to convince her to
put our attorney on the phone and she keeps refusing.
And finally I tell her it's an emergency, "Please put Jodi on the phone". And as soon as I hear her
voice on the other end of the phone I just completely break down. And I
explain to her, "Something is wrong with my dad and they won't let us get help for
him. She tells me
to just sit still,  sit tight and that she was going to see what she could do.
And so we're sitting there
and my dad continues to be in pain. After thirty to forty-five minutes
later, a man walks in and says our last name and all four of us get up
and we're following him, we're not sure where but
we're following him.  And we end up going to this
small office which - it was so small that only my Dad and I could barely fit in there. And there's a
man in there who's working on his desk. He
didn't even acknowledge that we were standing there he didn't speak to us one word.
He just hands us,  hands over this paper, and the
paper said that our visa had been extended for three months
so that we could go get my dad some medical help,
which we did right right away. And afterwards, the next three months is the
worst time of my life by far, because
we're afraid of..we're fearing deportation every single day.
And whenever we would see their mailman show up and put mail in our mailbox
it was like a dreaded task. We, none of us,wanted to go and check our mailbox.
And my dad's behavior was so completely over the top. He moves out of my mom's bedroom and
moves into the living room. And our blinds are closed whether it's day or
nighttime.
And he sleeps with a pair of clothes right next to him.
And whenever he would hear footsteps he would jump out of the couch and look through the blinds and see who it was.
was.
We finally go to our final appointment at the end of
the three months. And we walk in with our attorney and I notice that
it was a different judge who was sitting there, it was an older
gentleman and he looks really intense and
I remember the first time that I saw him, and my mind, I was so
intimidated by him because he wouldn't smile, he wouldn't talk, or anything like
that, and I was pretty intimidated because I had to translate whatever conversation
was going to happen because I was our family's translator.
So the judge carries on with our attorney for a little bit and then turns his attention
to my dad. And after some basic questions, he gets right into it
and starts, um,
asking my dad if he has a translator and my dad says this... My daughter will translate
for us. And he tells me what... he says, " Young lady, whatever
I say to you, you say, you translate exactly what I say, nothing more nothing less. And
whatever your dad says, you tell me exactly what he says nothing more nothing less." And I agree.
I agree.
He asks my dad questions, really
demeaning questions like, " Do I understand correctly?
That you came here on forged papers?" And my dad starts to say, "Well, yes,
but..." and he goes on this long explanation. And then he cuts
my dad off and says, "I just want to hear yes
or no, I don't care about the explanation, I don't need explanation." And so they
kind of, this conversation goes on like this. back and forth and it's not going well at all.
and finally
he tells my dad,
"You know, we here in the United States do not
give citizenship to people that break the law. We can't and I
won't." And as soon as I translate this to my dad
I just put my head down and I just start
praying.
And when I open up my eyes I see my dad rising out of his
seat. And he starts unbuckling his belt at which
point I'm thinking he's completely losing his mind. 'Cause I'm not sure what he's
getting ready to do. But he lifts up his shirt
on the right side. And in his native language, looks at the judge
and says,
"This is what the Communists did to me." He's pointing at
a four- to five-inch knife scar.
And then he lift..he pushes down his pants in the back and
turns around a little bit
and again says. "This what the communists did to me" pointing at
three gunshot wounds. And then
he takes off his shoes and takes off his socks and points at his
toes and says, "This is what the communists did to me." He's pointing
at his toenails which they had try to pull with pliers.
And I remember thinking, "I know
I am hearing what I'm hearing," but somehow
everything wasn't registering,
because as I am translating these
horrible things, I am also learning for the first time [becoming emotional]
about my dad's whereabouts.
In
all of those times that I didn't know where he was, he was in prison
being tortured. And in that moment
I have never felt more sorrow.
He continues
to tell the judge, "It's easy for you to judge me. You
sit in that seat and you wear this robe, but if you came on this side and you
looked at me, one man to another, you will see
that everything I did,  I did to save my children. I had no
other choice
and you might deny it right now, but had it been you, I know
you would do the same thing. And if you have to show the
American public that you didn't take it easy on us, I
understand. Send me back. I volunteer.
But please let my children stay. Please give my children a new home.
And then he just puts his head down and starts
just crying
like a baby. And the judges Leaves. We're on a break. And he
comes back after an hour. And as soon as he enters the room I notice that he doesn't
have his robe on, and we thought, "we're still on break". But he goes
up to his chamber and
grabs something and starts walking back down
and towards us. And we're pretty nervous because we're not sure why he's walking towards
us and the entire time his both eyes were on my dad.
He goes past me, behind me, and stops right next
to my dad. My dad turns his chair and looks at him up, and
he says,
"Mr. Samadzai, let me see your hand".
My dad shows him his hand and he puts a stamp on my dad's hand and
says, "Mr. Samadzai, I would like you to be the
one to stamp your children's papers."
Together they stamp our papers and when they move their hands
It reads, "Asylum granted".
He then flips the page to my parents' papers and
stamps it with the same stamp, then looks on to my dad
and still puts his hand on his shoulder and says,
"Welcome to America." It took
us eighteen years from the
day that we arrived here for me to be
granted an American citizenship. On January
29th, two thousand and nine, As I stood there
and I was sworn in as an American citizen, I pledged
allegiance to my new homeland.
And it is through my children, my two year old
son and in my unborn child in my womb, that I
will make sure that
this gratitude that overflows in my heart every
single day, will continue to live on long after I am gone. Thank
you.
[applause}